As we approach the end of the semester,
we also naturally approach,
uh,
the end of the Quixote.
And,
uh,
we,
we move on to the consideration of other works of his as well as reactions to
his works by two major writers,
uh,
Golf Gotland border.
So that'll be a next Thursday.
Uh,
today I,
uh,
I will talk about the end of the great novel.
Our next class I will devote to those other works and also to serve.
This is death.
Uh,
but before I want to address two topics that have a sort of fallen by the
wayside,
um,
humor on a savant.
This is a self portraits following my little essay in the casebook.
Dot.
You have presumably,
uh,
red,
other than slapstick,
uh,
on this slapstick kind of of humor that we find occasionally in the Quixote,
in the
episodes of the Indian part,
one for instance,
as well as some of the scatological instances,
churches,
the time when Santra defecates in the fueling hammers episode.
So this humorous is broader,
more encompassing,
sophisticated,
and it's,
uh,
it is laced with irony.
My irony,
I mean that there is a benign,
that attachment and discreet perspective from which humanity is being seen in
contrast to the mat hero don't get Hotez madness allows the narrator and the
reader to appreciate everyone's a folly.
Uh,
no one is safe.
not the priest,
the Duke graduates like Samsung Carrasco and not even the narrator himself.
Sanchez wisdom is another measure by which to judge other characters,
presumably better educated.
He is not just the wise fool.
Funny,
uh,
for the funny,
a man who stumbles upon truths by chance,
but the processor of natural,
uh,
reason which allows him to be right when others who are well-read are wrong.
I believe that the one who best encapsulate it surrenders his humor was the late
Lowery Nelson who was a professor for many years here at Yale.
He writes in his Savantas a collection of critical essays.
In the introduction,
he writes the following and you have a handout in which to follow my reading of
this,
uh,
quotation,
the one sign Lowery Nelson Jr
as the pictures of the human condition,
both Shakespeare and sell Vantis belonged to the select company.
Of those I would call universal ironist as distinct from 10 dentures from 10
dentures,
irony lists,
universal ironist contemplate the world with a kind of gentle resignation and
compassion in full knowledge of both the grand jurors and mysteries of human
life.
Among them,
uh,
I would number Chaucer checkoff CAFCA is available.
It is available then dentures ironist view the world from a programmatic stance,
connoting accusation,
bitter protest and Melia wrist reformation of human ills.
Miliaria meaning to make better among them.
I would include Florida,
Ipsen hardy and man.
The distinction is only approximate,
but nonetheless significant.
Neither attitude is qualitative,
qualitatively superior or justifiable.
Though it is perhaps the universal ironist who can view mankind with greater
tolerance and understanding,
it is he who can encompass a broader span of human types and human experiences.
It is he who can best present the inviolability and unique essence of the
particular and the individual.
It is precisely this ability in Shakespeare and said Avantis to create
particularized essence that leads us their readers to draw the general
conclusion,
to see the individual as representative.
Hence,
the seeming plenitude of humanity we find in such odd and peculiar figures as
don't be haughty and central Japan,
not to mention Samsung Carrasco the curate Marcella,
he nest the [inaudible] and Alice
particularized incident.
Essence means here I think,
uh,
that individual objects and specially characters are food within themselves in
there being the round.
This is why details are so important in the Quixote by the plenitude of
humanity.
Nelson means the foibles,
weaknesses,
and also the grand juror of these fingers.
I see,
says their mistakes there.
Bumps against the real are funny and counterbalance.
They're virtuous.
I only resides in the fulcrum where the two are added to each other.
We thought counseling each other with respect to Shakespeare though though I
agree with Nelson.
Uh,
I want to reiterate what I have said in previous classes.
There is a level of despair in his,
uh,
place,
that is never reached.
Instead Avantis Savantas has a gentler perspective on the human condition and a
more optimistic one.
Uh,
I'm thinking of course of hamlet and I'm thinking of course of King Lear
so much for humor,
although much more code.
And I should have been said throughout the semester.
Now as for the self portraits,
I included those texts because as I explain in the book the format of the case
book called for an interview with the author in question.
And since Advantis personnel available,
uh,
I thought that it would be,
best to include these texts that would make a good substitute.
I toyed with the idea of inventing an interview.
We said Advantis,
but I didn't think I could get it past the editors had a very staid and cereals
Oxford University press.
Um,
the things I would like you to remember from my,
uh,
little prologue or these that individualism led to portraiture in the
renaissance and also is,
uh,
that was also aided and helped by wealth,
that perspective and developing of perspective.
Think of Alberti of whom I have mentioned many times along the semester allowed
for a more realistic particularized kind of portrait,
showing significant details of the face and body.
Not all necessarily flattering,
although of course those who paid for the,
uh,
for the portraits wanted to be flattered that the first self portrait by a
painting that we know of was Albert Uva in which he shows he's piercing eyes and
fine hand the instrument of his craft
and that this self portrait announcers anticipates is better.
The one of Alaska's in Las Meninas where he appears in a prominent position full
of energy and self assurance in the act of painting.
Then there are the concomitant self portraits by Cervantes,
uh,
which are characteristically self deprecating.
Uh,
in one he talks about his,
uh,
the changing color of his hair.
In another he talks about his missing teeth and so forth.
So he,
he's,
he's self deprecating,
particularly with regards to the effects of time on his body.
Okay.
What I would add today,
uh,
is that we should see those self portraits in relation to the 1605,
a prologue to the Quixote Cervantes Self,
uh,
presentation as author.
It is certainly different from Velazquez,
uh,
who's much more self assured and self promoting obesity.
But perhaps it is,
this is the effect of the different mediums that they are using,
painting and literature,
but most likely it is a difference in their personalities.
Now we get to Don Quixote's return home.
The novels plot with this repeated returns home suggests that life consists of
going and coming back,
sort of a compressed Elliot and these together and is made up of a series of
apparent repetitions,
ringing counters and help release both parts and with a return,
uh,
after a return home after a Sally actually there,
there are three returns,
it seems as if don't get halted.
The whole novel is suggesting that in fiction there are two basic plots,
one going out and the other one coming back,
one the Iliad and the other one,
the Odyssey.
That's too simplistic,
but there seems to be that suggestion in the combined two parts of the cohort.
Okay,
what do these repetitions reveal?
What,
what do we learn from them?
Perhaps not to live is to live again.
And that life includes the remembrance of life,
I suppose,
would discover and exploit over two centuries later in his great novel check.
Should you don't pedagogy remembers of things passed in English.
A great work that I hope you have the chance to read someday if you have it yet.
That is why we approach the end by returning to the beginning in the process.
Cervantes says,
once again,
underline that reality has become fictionalized in part two independent of Don
Quixote and that his own hero belongs to the grade fictions of the ages to the
great characters of ages have been mentioned in this.
And I will repeat it now.
Uh,
when I comment upon some,
uh,
passage,
said about this also in this return and I will go over it on the scores.
The nature of Don Quixote is victory,
which I,
uh,
mentioned in,
with regards to nes India need.
So as he returns,
okay,
what defines a character from the Apocryphal Quixote?
Don't Alvarado they terrify.
I have red nails,
Quixote and I can assure you that this character appears in that
it is as if he's memories had a life outside of himself in literature.
Cervantes is of course,
again poking fun at Area Neda.
Uh,
but the way he does is full of other suggestions.
As I mentioned in a previous class and I referred to the work by stiff at
Gilman.
The first and clearest is a don Quixote lives in a world of fiction
that intersects that over via Nader's,
uh,
fiction.
It is the ultimate proof that in this part to reality has become fictionalized.
As I mentioned earlier,
without the help of Don Quixote is fantasy.
It is out there already fictionalized characters from two different fictional
books,
meat and one asks the other to sign a document,
a,
uh,
and notarized document to testify that the booking which he appeared it was
false and that he is the real one.
This is enormously funny.
At a very sophisticated level.
Uh,
the document is crucial,
uh,
as legality would be the ultimate way of guaranteeing that a fiction is real
serve.
Anthesis.
Perhaps remembering here the legal document out of which picker rescue fiction
issued.
Remember that I mentioned several times that the picaresque begins as the
position,
the legal document of a criminal addressing a judge.
And so this is not the end of [inaudible] because as you remember,
uh,
after Doki hotter regains his sanity,
he asks to be forgiven by [inaudible],
for having induced enticed him to write such a bad book.
So then they come to the last in,
remember we talked about the first in and now we get to the last in the first
in,
in part one,
remember with the prostitutes and the Fisher he served and all of that where
he's made a night.
Here we get to the last in which does not confused with a,
uh,
a castle anymore.
At the last end were don Quixote on central lodge.
On the way back there room contains representations of Helen,
of Troy and Dido.
The passage I believe is one more example of services awareness,
uh,
of the importance of his creation.
This is some pages to ninth,
27,928 in the Jarvis translation and it goes as follows.
He was lodged in a ground room.
He know Quixote with paint,
with painted search.
Search is a kind of base kind of cloth and not very instead of tapestry as it's
the fashion of country towns in one of the pieces was painted by a wretched
hand.
The rape of Helen when the daring guests carried her off from men,
allows in another was the history of died on an s.
She upon a high tower us making signals with have a bet half a bed sheet to her
fugitive guests who was out at sea flying away from her in a figured or
Brigantine.
He observed in the two history pieces that Helen went away with.
No very ill will for.
She was slightly laughing to herself,
but the beauteous Dido seem to let fall from her eyes.
Tears as big as one knots which don't be haughty.
Seeing.
He said these two ladies were most unfortunate in not being born in this age and
I above all men on happy that I was not born in theirs for her.
I encountered those gardens.
Neither Troy been burned.
Neither had Troy being burned,
nor Carthage.
Destroyed since by my killing Paris.
Only since by my killing Paris.
Only.
All these mischiefs had been prevented.
I hold a wager go Santo that here belonged.
There will not be either visualing house tavern in or barbershop in which the
history of our over exploits will not be painted,
but I could wish they may be done by the hand of a better painter done.
Uh,
uh,
he that did these and quotes,
anyone who has been to Spain,
especially to battery Bara hustles airport,
I'm very amused by the name of that airport all the time,
but I asked me is playing cards,
but Barbara has to simply the name of the town in which the airport was built.
Um,
any one who has been to Spain,
especially to my needs,
but our house airport,
no central has worn the wager for,
there are hundreds of painted and sculpted figurines of Doki hotel on central of
every kind of for sale,
including mousepads for computers.
Believe me.
In fact,
the statutes of Doki Hotel on central grace,
the plaza,
they Spania in Madrid.
If you have been to Madrid,
you have seen them.
I'm sure if you have not,
when you do,
you will go see them.
I'm sure too,
uh,
we have several images of them.
I believe that Spain is the only country in which there are statutes of
fictional characters.
I don't think that there is a statue of the pilgrim in Dante's commedia in Italy
as far as I know,
or hamlet in England.
As far as I know,
it's very,
it's quite remarkable.
Uh,
such has been the identification of the Quixote with Spain,
Spanish culture and the Spanish language that has,
which we'll see a bit later,
some of its modern writers,
some of the modern Spanish writers when I'm more know,
have even spoken of a religion of quick so autism really young.
They'll Quixote small.
There we are.
Cervantes knew that his protagonist would be one with those of classical times.
Heti assumption for an artist of the 16th and 17th century whose reverence for
classical art was immense.
Uh,
I don't know if we could of course foreseeing that there will be a statues of
his,
of his protagonists in his town of Madrid.
Um,
it is a realization
that he hold the importance of,
of his characters in vertical,
particular them.
Kiata based on the accomplishment of his hero,
which as I have been saying is quite different from those of the likes of nes.
Don Quixote returns at conqueror of himself,
says the Saint Joe as they enter their village.
And I quote now from,
uh,
our,
translation
page nine 33 open dine arms and receive likewise,
he's addressing the on named village as they come into the town.
Thy Son,
Don Quixote receive likewise dies son Don Quixote,
who if it comes conquered by another hand,
yet he comes a conqueror of himself,
which as I have heard him say,
is the greatest victory that can be desired,
unquote.
This is donkey hope,
this greatest triumph.
What does this mean?
I the most literal level,
it means that he has accepted his defeat at the hands of the night of the White
Moon,
uh,
gracefully and is willing to abide by the rules,
agreed upon before combat with,
uh,
with at night of the white moon.
Uh,
in that way he has conquered himself.
but it may also mean what I have suggested,
uh,
that denied of the white moon is a reflection of donkey halter himself,
hence that he has vanquished,
been vanquished by his,
his,
his own protection by himself.
I think that more broadly speaking,
it means I don't,
Quixote has come to know himself better and extend and accept himself for what
he is,
that he has vanquish with hin him,
his madness,
or he's about,
as we heard in the quotation about Helen and Dido,
this has not been quite accomplished yet.
He talks about the feeding Paris,
but we have also seen that since the cave of Montesinos episode don't care how
they as been dealing differently with reality and with himself.
So he's return is a triumphant one according to,
uh,
to Sanctu.
There is also an echo of here of the Greek Nova itself.
Uh,
but don't be haughty has,
has a vanquish himself because he has come to really know himself.
So we finally come to the end.
Uh,
we should begin by pondering why ends or endings are so important.
Let me summarize what Frank Kermode says in his beautiful book.
The sense of an ending from 1966 I will get to a long quotation from that book
that you have in a handout with the bibliographic information about the book by
Kermode.
By now his third Frank Kermode is an Englishman who was knighted by the Queen,
uh,
an excellent critical,
the better,
perhaps the best Greek of the English language.
Although I see that,
uh,
tremor Rose Lee because if Harold bloom here is that I have said something like
that,
my life may be in danger.
Every time I leave this class or another class I encounter Harold bloom who
yells at the top of his lungs hard robotic door.
Here comes the second best critic at Yale,
meaning that he of course is the first to which I answer Harold.
We belonged to different generations and you belong to the one that is past.
There's a right to defend oneself
even from this night of the white moon.
All of us in the modern era.
I think that we live in a world of crisis that is at the end of an epoch and the
beginning of the next,
hence,
we are keenly concerned with a sense of what we perceive as the impending end,
the sense that it can give to the past,
the sense that that end can give to the past
and to the future.
The fictions that we create reflect this anxiety and are designed to show the
Concorde of the Midwest.
We just want to kermode a course,
our condition man or women in the Midwest in the middle.
These mirrors that we inhabit,
a with the beginnings and ends,
uh,
these fictions in which there is this relationship between beginning and end.
Uh,
our kermode calls fictions of Concord.
There seems to be according to him,
human need to relate beginnings to end to ends.
Even if we are not religious believers or believers in secular versions of
providence like Marxism,
providence from provi dead,
it means to a foresight to uh,
uh,
but most mostly providence means the care of a benevolent,
God who guides our,
our,
our lives and our steps.
Apocalypse is one of the fictions.
Concord,
it ends,
transforms and it's concordance.
Apocalypse is from the Greek to uncover,
uh,
which means revelation.
Hence the book of revelation.
The last in the new testament prophecy is another form.
Uh,
it tells us the shape of the future connects the precedence with that end and
beyond.
We are born in the middle and according to Kermode to make sense of our span,
we need fictive Conchords with origins and ends.
So just give meanings.
Two lives and two poems.
I'm quote,
Millennia,
rhythm.
The end is near.
You have seen all of these uh,
uh,
cartoons.
What was the guy's holding the cardboard saying the end is near repent and so
forth.
Uh,
millennialism has to do with a thousand years,
uh,
with something lasting a thousand years.
Like those who believe that the end of the world would come in the year 1000 and
some,
even in the year 2000,
if you remember back in 2000,
there were all kinds of prophecies.
Of course,
all these people who prophesied a are quick to recalculate.
If it doesn't happen,
they recalculate.
It wasn't in the year 1000 it was a since the death of Christ,
the thousand 33 I mean they always calculate recalculate.
The year 2000 came and went and we bought it.
Many people were waiting for all kinds of catastrophes to happen.
We asked them is another word you should remember.
Okay.
[inaudible] from the Greek for 1000 if they believe that Christ will rise in a
thousand years,
so we have beginning man or woman in the Middle East and end
on in the long quote that I will read now from Carol about,
this is how he explained it in a very charming way.
Let us take a very simple example.
The ticking of a clock.
We ask why did says and we agreed that it says tick tock.
Of course this is only in English.
In Spanish it goes
big duck [inaudible].
Since we are speaking English,
it's stick puck by this fiction.
We humanize it,
making it talk.
Our language,
of course it is.
We who provide the fictional difference between the two.
Sounds.
Take is our word for a physical beginning park our word for an end,
we say they differ.
What enables him to be different.
It's a special kind of middle.
We can perceive it.
You only when it is organized,
it can be shown by experiment that subjects who listened to rhythmic structure
such as tick tock repeat identically repeated identically can reproduce the
intervals with within the structure accurately,
but they cannot grasp spontaneously the interval between the rhythmic groups.
That is uh,
the rhythmic group is thick,
dark,
okay.
Each group is stick doc,
so they cannot,
uh,
as generally grasp the interval between rhythmic groups that he's between talk
and pick when the sec,
the,
the next group begins.
Okay.
They talk
the talk.
So Talk Dick.
Okay.
Anyone came in and listened to me now would certainly
conclude that I have gone bonkers.
That donkey hope,
this madness is really contagious.
Uh,
that first interval is organized and limited tick tock and the second is not
according to Paul phrase,
I don't know who it is that the Toc tic gap is analogous to the role of the
ground and spacial perception after this is blurry and on differentiated.
Each is characterized by a lack of form against which the illusory organization
of shape and rhythm are perceived in the spacial or temporal object.
The fact that we call the second of the dual related sounds talk,
it's evidence that we use fiction to enable the end to confer organization and
form of temporal structure on temporal structure.
The interval between the two sounds between tick and talk is now charged with a
significant duration.
The clock tick tock I take to be the model for what we call a plot,
the plot or an organization that humanizes time by giving it form and the
interval between talking tick represents purely successive disorganized time of
the sword.
We need to humanize.
That's the end of this stuff I think illustrative of a quotation,
so the end is meaning the end provides meaning and this is why it is so
necessary.
He goes on Kermode men in the Mideast make considerable imaginative investments
in coherent patterns,
which by the provision of an end make possible is satisfying consonance with
origins.
And with the middle,
I'm quoting the plots of our poems plays and novels reflect that need for
significant endings.
So what is,
what is the significance of donkey hope,
this ending or is it significant?
In the next to the last chapter,
sanctuary discards the omens that don Quixote sees in various things and events
as they come into the village omens,
which would connect the end of the novel with a future beyond it.
They are prophetic.
I'm calling from nine 34.
Mahlum signum malunion think signal.
This is Latin bad sign,
but sign a hair.
Floyd's dogs pursuer don't see now,
appears not.
Says don't you hope they remember the hair that is running and uh,
under the Sandra actually catches because you're so tired,
so tired.
Um,
in the Spanish act actually says [inaudible],
uh,
Jarvis has given it to syntax,
which in Spanish it does not happen.
Uh,
the donkey healthy has abandoned syntax,
uh,
on,
appears to speak in tongues as if you were having a vision or a revelation,
which is what he's trying to find in this.
And this bad omens is this Mullum signum that he sees.
Okay.
The incident shows that in his subconscious don Quixote is still in the world of
dreams and of literature where this concourse ochre the prophetic would extend
that world for closing,
unending.
But as I said,
central dismisses but central dismisses this omens,
uh,
in a very wise way appealing to Christian doctrine.
It isn't as if [inaudible] himself where here wavering about how to end the
novel,
but what is the meaning of the end?
Cervantes does give the novel.
There are in the Quixote three forms of potential closure,
Cervantes closer to Quixote in three ways.
First,
donkey hope that is defeated.
Second,
he regains his sanity.
Third,
he dies.
One could say that this scheme points were three part tide conception of reality
or of the worlds in which don't be hotel lifts with each form of closure
corresponding to each of the three of giving you a handout with a kind of crass,
primitive representation of these three worlds as concentric circles that I've
made myself.
And uh,
and this is why,
and it shows it,
but I hope that it is clear enough.
First,
the fictional world of chivel re no Quixote is defeated.
This is the realm of books.
Second present day reality.
Don't hope the returns to being alone.
Saki high.
No,
they're good.
Third,
donkey holder dies.
Um,
presumably reaches the true reality that is the afterlife.
Hence life itself was like a fiction.
Uh,
indicted was the femoral and made up of things of dubious substance.
It's a self contained Merkel safe fiction of Concord at possible.
Fourth form of closure at admit of fictional level would be the defeat of your
apocryphal.
But let us go over the city in more detail.
First,
the fictional world of chilvery don't get healthy is defeated by the night of
the white moon.
Hence,
he's quest comes to an end within his madness and within the fiction of Geo
Valerie Romances.
But as I said in the last class,
and I said a few minutes ago,
there are signs that denied of the white moon is like a reflection of the call
to himself or if it's madness and more profoundly of nothingness.
That was his,
he's,
he's very fragile,
being just very fragile self.
Uh,
this is why this,
this,
this night is white,
almost transparent,
uh,
ghost of Don Quixote.
Uh,
so this defeat within the world of books,
announcers or prefigures,
he's regaining his,
uh,
sanity and even announces he's death us quite so just nothingness.
Nothingness.
Hence it suggests death.
Okay?
Then there is present day reality along.
So he,
Hannah regains insanity.
It is like a conversion story.
The conversion story is typical.
Typically the man who,
uh,
the old man dies and the new mine is reborn.
That is the conversion story.
Uh,
so that he said death and resurrection,
a involved don't be haughty.
Sleeps and awakens changed us if he had undergone a mystical experience similar
to the sleep and awakening after the cave of Montesinos episodes episode,
which prefigure this one.
How can he know that he has now awakened to his true self and real world?
Don't be haughty,
had the memory of who he had been,
but if this life,
but if his life has no Quixote is now complete and his life is about to be
complete his life as I want to be handled.
What differentiates the two?
This is the conundrum of sickies mingle in Calderon's life is a dream that
played that I have recounted to you several times where the young princess is
drug taken to the palace.
He commits all kinds of,
uh,
of crimes,
his drug taking back to the tower and weeks.
He can't tell if it was a dream,
what he experienced,
uh,
in the,
in the palace or if it is a reason now,
if he's now dreaming in the tower,
he can't tell.
So he's Mundos answering Calderon's play is to cut through the ambiguity and
will himself to be good,
to be good because life maybe a dream,
but it may be a rehearsal for a life that is more enduring.
Now,
the afterlife,
that outer circle,
Don Quixote death,
he dies by the way,
uh,
I,
I don't know if you have taken notice of this,
but he dies on married and without succession,
which is evident in the,
in the scene with a notary when he's dictating his testament,
because he has to leave everything to his niece and friends and so forth.
Again,
it is very much,
like I say,
he's moonless awakening into the dream like quality of life itself.
It is as if all of life were like a dream.
He's madness was a dream within a dream and death.
The only access to a true permanent life.
Hence,
it is not only his madness that is like a dream,
but everything else is madness is the dream.
Within a dream,
only death can put an end to the play of reflections.
And in a way,
this is why alone Saki handle has to die.
Donkey,
donkey health,
US death is the last in a series of mock deaths that have appeared throughout
the book and prefigure this one one at the end of part one when he's knocked
unconscious.
Uh,
then of course in the,
uh,
in the cave of Montesinos Doki helped us death is the last in a,
in a series of mock vest.
As I've said,
one has to take into account that the death of Don Quixote,
at least within the plot of the novel,
is also a kind of return Gnocchi.
Hope that returns home,
do the Heimlich to use Freud's work,
the familiar to the place where he was alone.
Sukarno where he was saying this makes the entire series of episodes that make
up the whole book his madness,
like a bubble or a dream.
All the more so it is like they Barataria episodes are two central,
but the dream repetitions of his current lead,
one to consider the fiction in between as something that one could dispense
with.
Do the events within that bubble occur in some sort of concert with one another
or either they themselves,
just a series of repetitions is there in successive sense to the novels plot you
there as sequential quality to the novel,
the temporal,
the temporality in the Quixote that leads to that end.
For instance,
we have been able to more or less follow the months and even the days during
which the adventures take place.
But is there a sense of temporality,
of chronology,
of inevitability?
We know that he has to return at some point to the village as he did before and
once he's defeated,
we know that he's madness is now on the wane.
There is inevitability in the transience of his madness of this,
of this invention of self.
I don't know if it's very life.
Uh,
on the other hand,
a close reading of the last chapter does not reveal anything about the death of
[inaudible] Ahmed.
They're winning.
Haley for instance.
Uh,
when did see the,
I met their billing heavy die.
There is no total closure in the hotel possible.
I think said one this place with it.
Ironically,
he knows that no matter how many times is it okay hold this dead and that Cedia
Metis is hanging in his pen and addressing his pen,
that any writer can still come up as one Montalvo did.
I think I may have mentioned him before.
Equatorian writer who wrote a wonderful book.
Okay.
Cold chapters.
That's the [inaudible] does for God
and a is a pastiche meaning an eh,
Eh,
imitating [inaudible].
This is a style.
So fair amount.
This,
no.
So we will talk about that when we talk about [inaudible] the story by borders
in our next class.
Don Quixote.
Quixote is not a book that has a plot in the Aristotelian sense with a
beginning,
a middle and an end all tied together tightly in a sequence of events leading to
a finish.
It is the life of Don Quixote that gives it form as in the picaresque,
the life of the picker who gives form to the narrative.
Uh,
or we can think here again of what he missed.
The PASA.
Monte said jokingly about not finishing his book because his life is on finish.
Poking fun at that autobiography as a convention.
The book has to end with his death.
Death is a form of closure that everyone understands.
It gives life shape.
Uh,
give a ago,
Francisco [inaudible] it great port of the 17th century.
I urge you to read goodwill on one way to do so,
is to tell you that he wrote some of the most obscene pumps in the history of
the Spanish language.
Also Sabal the most beautiful love poems.
Uh,
perhaps,
uh,
border has said that me,
the was a whole literature all by himself.
He has a poem in which he about death in which he ends by saying that death will
organize his life.
We'll give it a meaning.
Okay.
So,
uh,
that provides an enter,
which everything will seem to have been pointing.
I used to tell him plots or the,
the ones that will be,
they talk
unless you believe that there is a tight concert to the world and to history or
less,
you begin to believe in providence in this sense that vantage is showing that
the novel as a form cannot be bound by this artificial shapes of art,
like the epic tragedy.
But by the shape of life was everyone understands it.
So baggy monster that he has created in the normal.
This is profoundly so when we take into account,
I said,
well this his own death is near as he writes about Don Quixote's,
his death and we we'll be talking about [inaudible] death in the next class.
This is also the reason why that is.
For instance,
no closure to the story of Anna Felix.
We got this daughter,
uh,
one may ask also why they're so little about don Quixote's birth and use.
One could say that the only life of Don Quixote that is worth knowing is his
life as the math night.
That everything else is of little consequence.
So it is the life that don't be haughty authored for himself.
That is important in the conception,
execution and structure of the book.
But it is a life not a completed action in the Aristotelian Sense.
Why not end the book then by making him sane
is sane donkey hotel would close the plot of Loki halters metal life,
his life as art and literature.
One answer would be to say that only by making him diag and said Vantis blurred
and his diction between our daily lives and the invented lives of literature
both have endings with significance.
So look,
your daughter's death as Don Quixote and his rebirth as a long econo.
It's not enough to close the book.
You also had to die.
But only if the main theme of the book is I'm,
I believe that it is the own reality of worldly life and our hope for a real
life after,
after death.
Now I'm going to just mention what some authors,
major authors said about the shape of the Quixote since we were,
since we can look at it as a whole sheet.
And I,
uh,
will then we get to the author I mentioned before,
Miguel de Amino,
I may have mentioned him before.
I mentioned certainly Ortega.
You got set,
who was the great Spanish philosopher of the 20th century,
Miguel de Una [inaudible].
What's a philosopher but also a writer and novelist,
the port.
It's thinker in general.
He was the president of the University of Salamanca,
what we would call today,
a public intellectual.
He was exiled by the dictatorship of premolar Rivera.
Uh,
and uh,
he wrote,
he was a Basque born in Bilbao in 1864 and died in Salamanca in 1936 just at the
beginning of the Spanish civil war.
Can you,
you may have heard some of the titles of some of his books.
They'll think Demian [inaudible] on the tragic sense of life book that I
recommend that you read.
La Rania,
they'll Christianity the agony of Christianity and a very,
very well known novel called Nebula missed from 1914 in 1905
don't,
eh,
no published viva.
They don't be haughty essential the life of Don Quixote and sanctuary,
which is a commentary chapter by chapter of the Quixote.
Very,
uh,
sweet,
generous kind of commentary when I'm,
or like to be outrageous.
For instance,
when I'm mono says that he believes or phase to believe in the real existence of
Don Quixote on claiming that Cervantes,
a mediocre writer by a stroke of luck.
Got to write the story written about the pair.
Buy One CD.
I made been Benning Hailey go.
This is his conceit.
So he ran.
I was against it.
[inaudible] uh,
Luna Muno there is no assurance that,
uh,
the donkey holiday we'll find a life after death.
This is talking about the death of Don Quixote,
uh,
stressing that perhaps this life is all there is and that it is like God's
dream.
Yeah.
So he hopes that God will go on dreaming us.
He says humorously,
because if he stops dreaming,
we will all disappear along with the universe.
God gave us the desire to be immortal like him and created a symbol of it in Don
Quixote who does what he does because he wants to be immortal.
So now Muno mourns Don Quixote's passing and rising against this for
trivializing his death and he affirms that I at least don't Quixote,
uh,
passed on his badness to Joe.
You remember in the last scene there were San Angelo says,
don't die.
Please.
Level's gone now.
And,
uh,
soy de Santo,
who will carry on with the madness when I won't know it goes on to say that
Antonia key,
Hannah Denise does.
Mary is sensible,
boring man who never heard of Geo Valerie Romances.
Therefore,
she inherits a key,
forces us into live at home drum,
live devoid of adventure.
I know husband who takes out the garbage
sure,
but takes no risks.
Don't see now,
however,
or I'll,
those are Lorenzo on the other hand,
does understand her elevation to idea lady
and she leads men to heroic action.
That is the idea.
The ideal of such a lady leads men to ideal action,
meaning to take risks.
She and Santo keep alive according to the religion of Don Quixote,
which is on the wane in Spain as he writes his book in 1905,
he complaints with Spain having been defeated in the Spanish American war by the
United States.
For him,
it's this defeat signals the end of [inaudible] small.
This,
uh,
having been defeated by this upstart nation and he,
he loans for every turn of the quixotic spirit to Spain,
one that rebels against commonplace reality and up horse mediocrity.
On submissiveness,
he belonged to the store called generation of 98,
which was a collection of riders,
a group of writers.
Oh,
who all wrote about the,
uh,
the miseries of Spain at the turn of the century.
And,
uh,
particularly,
complaining about the defeat,
uh,
at the hand of the United States.
There is a moment in this,
in the Spanish American war that I,
that I call a quixotic moment.
It is the following.
This is to what degree your country can absorb a fictional writer,
uh,
j,
[inaudible] Pasqual set Aveda ice.
They liked them.
You want it,
okay.
Got himself trapped with a whole Spanish fleet in some Geralda Quba Bay,
Santiago's Bay,
Cuba,
like,
oh Cuban base have the virtue of being very broad and with a very narrow
entrance.
Servera got into the bay with all of his ships,
which are wooden or fashion and gangster didn't have much range.
The American fleet solution itself outside waiting for the inevitable moment
when Siddha Veda either gave up or tried to leave instead of where I
communicated with Spain,
they had cable at the time about his predicament.
And the Spanish government answered saying,
we know that with your valor vigor and a an an all of your intelligence and
cunning,
you will be able to prevail.
We already you to come out.
So the Spanish fleet came out and it was a Turkey shoot.
The American fleet shot every single one of the Spanish ships instead of,
then I writes about this,
I've read his memoirs a lot.
He was very satisfied that at least the Americans pull him out of the water.
He went down with the ship.
The Americans pulled him out of his water with his sword and everything,
put him on board and treated him with great deference and a send.
The surviving,
the few surviving sailors were sent as Britain as a war to Maine for a while
where he was able to visit them later set Aveda was later through food by the
American sued by the Spanish government for losing the fleet.
So that was a quick Sadik moment of the kind who would have applauded
so much.
[inaudible] Borges,
Jorge Luis Borges.
We're going to speak more about him in our next class.
What he wrote,
the marvelous I say about the last chapter of the Quixote,
he points out,
I think I've mentioned this before,
that the one quality that Unites Don Quixote and alone Saki,
Hanno is courage.
That alone,
Saki,
Hanno faces death with courage and serenity.
So this is the one quality that they have in common,
even if one is sane and the other one is mad.
Okay?
Uh,
he writes that sort of anthrax could have chosen a more astonishing episode to
bring about Don Quixote is returned to sanity,
but shows sleeping.
That mysterious world from which we returned when we awaken,
not knowing where we have been.
This is what bar has picks on that go six hours of sleep,
that those six hours of sleep are like death so that Don Quixote dies and he's
wrestle.
Rick did as Alonzo Kiano,
uh,
board has remarks on the sort of what he calls it,
lateral and casual way in which Don Quixote dies at the end of a sentence.
If you were followed the ending there sort of is at the end of the center,
but I mean that he died
and he writes,
it is the last of many cruelties that Cervantes has visited upon his hero.
Perhaps this cruelty cruelty is a form of modesty and Avantis and Don Quixote
understand Castro
each other well and forgive each other rights.
Uh,
Boris,
uh,
bore his claims of the whole book was written for this last scene of,
of death.
I am willing to finish,
uh,
with the image that you have on the title page of your syllabus,
which is of course the one by Pablo Picasso,
whom you all know.
Of course it was a Spanish painter,
although he lived in France most of his life and all of that.
But he was a Spanish painter,
born in Malaga in 1881 and died in 1973.
I left the Gospel for last.
He's Quixote,
as I said,
and as you know,
is on the title page of your syllabus.
Uh,
I think that because whiskey hotel is so schematic because he considers him an
archetype,
an archetype,
Ferris chaotic,
uh,
by nature.
Notice,
of course the skeletal Racine antic
are made up of lines.
Uh,
the plump Santo.
Yeah.
Um,
the donkey's ears.
I think that the donkey's ears,
how,
what are their signature?
And in Spanish,
bull is a donkey and it means someone who's dumb.
So you can,
you know,
your point ears like that if you're a donkey.
So this is why the donkey's ears are so prominent.
I,
if Picasso has injected some humor in his painting,
which I think is quite appropriate,
the windmills in the background or Don Quixote signature and the bright sun
beating down on him,
his Castille's hot sun,
which is pressing through much of the novel.
But what is not so evident,
it seems to me,
until you look for a while,
is that okay?
Hottest figure is like,
like Laka interogation back.
The figure of Oakey Horta is like an interrogation.
Mark
the question mark in English,
I'm sorry,
I'm translating from Spanish.
[inaudible] question mark.
Your languages tend to get mixed up.
There are advantages and disadvantages to knowing several languages.
So I'll leave you with that question mark of the castles.